- I do think that people are psychic.
Do I think all the psychics that you see
on the block are actually psychic? No.
I definitely think there are a select few
that have the ability.
(spooky music)
- Never heard of Zener cards in my life.
- No, I have not heard of Zener cards.
- I don't know that I realized
they were called that,
but I recognize from
the movie Ghostbusters.
- Square.
- Good guess.
But wrong.
(electrical zapping)
- So, I guess the whole way this works is
we're guessing which shape.
- Whoever gets the most right,
the winner is going to be shot--
shooting the loser with this.
- It's like Ripley's gun.
- Okay, so it's either river, plus signs,
star, square, or circle.
I gotta figure out which one.
(electrical buzzing)
Star.
- Oh, Jordan's psychic!
- It's a plus sign.
- Hmm, squiggly lines.
- It was a circle.
- Aww...
It's sort of squiggly lines.
- Circle.
Bitch!
- Plus?
- It's a star.
- Square.
- Squiggly lines.
I was actually guessing the next card.
- Triangle.
Damn.
Triangle? There is no triangle!
- Oh, (beep).
- Concentrating really hard.
It's a star.
No!
- Star.
Please be a star.
Oh.
- She got it right.
- I got it, I just tap into my mind.
I've gotta believe in myself.
And I've gotta feel the
power coming through me.
- I believe in you.
- Star.
- No...
- Mother---
You know what? Screw this game, screw it.
- Circle?
- She got it right.
- Square.
- Squiggly lines again.
- Again?
- I don't know, I definitely feel like
I would not be able to be responsible
with any sort of psychic ability.
I feel like I would just be
abusing that all the time.
- I've always wanted to do this.
I was so sure I would totally
nail it if I ever did it.
I'm never gonna do it
again so I can always say,
- She was right.
- "Well, I was right
two out of three times."
- I thought that people could possess
like cool superpowers, psychic abilities.
I thought I could gain my
abilities on my 18th birthday.
And then that didn't happen so after that
things went downhill from there.
(laughs)
- Well it looks like I'm
getting shot with a Nerf gun.
- I'm so sorry.
- Um, I'll try to be good to you.
- [Daraius] Oh my God.
(laughs)
(Nerf gun revs up)
- [Jordan] Selorm, I'm sorry.
(Nerf gun firing repeatedly)
- (beep) shit!
No! Ouch, ow!
Okay, that's enough!
He said one!
- [Daysha] Oh my God!
- She missed!
(laughs)
- [Daysha] This is terrifying.
(screams)
(laughs)
- Okay, I can't do that anymore.
I'm so sorry.